on en fait une caméra ici qu'il a mesuré
la hauteur du sol enfin bon sable et en
fonction de la hauteur il va mettre un
jeu de couleurs vous voyez plus on est
haut
un bac à sable interactif qui changent
de couleur en fonction des formes quand
le réel rencontre le virtuel c'est le
principe de la réalité augmentée ou à
utiliser des casques ou des interfaces
plus transparente qui nous permettent de
voir le monde tel qu'il est mais en plus
on va rajouter par dessus des
informations virtuelles et numérique en
3d qui vont apparaître aux utilisateurs
ça peut être justement l'apparition d'un
personnage une création de fenêtres le
bac à sable on va dire à ce côté très
ludique est coté direct en plus on a un
peu l'impression de se prendre pour dieu
on fabrique des paysages ont fait
pleuvoir donc y avancent eux ce côté
très ludique un outil pédagogique pour
comprendre les nouvelles technologies et
leur utilisation
car même si le futur semble loin il est
bien présent
on peut voir comment l'eau ruisselle sur
le terrain mais aussi stagne à
différents endroits et donc cet au
revoir
elle reste après justement c'est
intéressant pour les enfants de voir
aussi comment ça peut fonctionner pour
voir russe qui peut en faire
ce qu'il retient aussi ils seront
certainement plus à mener encore que
nous à l'utiliser les apprentis
scientifiques sont attendus
régulièrement à la commanderie des
templiers
d'autres expériences sont proposés pour
les prochains ateliers il faudra
apprendre à fabriquer un hologramme ou
utilisé de la peinture connectés